this is funny there's probably echoes
that represent the 20th century now
in old man in the sea by hemingway
that uh also has
similar i guess themes but more um
more personal
more focused on the
i mean i guess it's less about god is
almost more like the existentialist
version of moby dick
yeah yeah and hence shorter and a lot
shorter yeah well hemingway was
brilliant that way yeah
uh but do you see echoes and uh do do
you find old man in the sea interesting
it's been since ninth grade that i've
been in
even longer ago than the fountainhead uh
so i didn't know we were gonna go there
i mean i find hemingway interesting but
hemingway my general sort of picture of
him is that you know he's he's uh we
have to confront the the dangers and the
difficulties of our life we have to
develop in ourselves a certain kind of
courage and manliness and i think
there's something interesting about that
he's for risk
in a certain way and i think that's
important uh but i but i do i don't now
i i don't have any right to say this
since it's been so long since i read it
i i do feel like there's there's
i don't remember
a sense for the for the quite the
tragedy of it maybe there is is it a
melancholy novel i don't even remember
no it's uh
i mean it has a sense like the stranger
by camus
it has a sense of like this is how life
is
and it's like
it has more about old age and
that uh you're not quite the man you
used to be feeling of like this is how
time passes
and then the the passing of time and how
you get old and you get older
and this is one last fish
it's it's less about this is the fish
it's more like this is one last fish
like and asking
who was
i who was i as a man as a human being in
this world and this one fish helps you
ask that question fully wonderful but
it's one fish which is just sort of all
the other fish too right and and that is
a big difference because
for
for ahab
no other fish will do than moby dick
it's got to be the biggest the most
powerful the most tormenting it's got to
be the one that you've got history with
that has defiled you
and it is uh
it's a raucous ride moby dick yeah
you